welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about which planets
have the best neighborhoods to settle
into
after your home world is randomly
destroyed by a being from another
dimension
my name is mt and i'm here today with
the one and only
jessica clemens what's going on jess hey
i'm ready to become the realtor of the
universe
find your new home planet so you just
your family's all gone and dead
well that's too bad plenty of real
estate's opportunity
in outer space jupiter
you will die from it being too cold like
there's no air here but there's plenty
of free real estate
they're like damn i can make a farm here
but everything will die
um did you hear that in in japan that
they're giving away like 500
homes basically like selling homes for
five hundred dollars
which is pretty great i gotta i gotta
get off this right right i gotta get off
this call right now so i got a ticket
i got i got a i got a prior a prior
situation going on are we ready to jump
into this oh yes
are you ready are we ready let's do it
so you guys recently on loki we saw
the moon destroying doom heading for the
people of lomantis one
according to the timekeepers this
civilization was supposed to be wiped
out
but even if everyone on the mantas one
were able to escape
where would they even go there would
just be another exiled civilization in
the mcu looking for a home
which seems to be a huge major theme if
you know what i'm saying
are the creative forces at marvel trying
to tell us something this all leads
to our week's big question which is can
we see the destruction of earth in the
main mcu dimension
that is a good question because whenever
kevin feige does something in the mcu
he does tend to do it to prepare people
for something bigger like in loki
we're getting the introduction of
variance which is basically a primer for
multiverse of madness and and everything
that's gonna happen in in doctor strange
two and everything moving forward and
probably quantomania too now it is true
that the mcu loves to wipe out
civilizations or at least put them on
the run it's a powerful narrative device
that comes with an extremely high stakes
for the characters involved
plus it gives the audience a way to
instantly understand a character's
motivations and empathize with their
motivations to protect their home
but could there be more to it than that
could marvel be prepping us for
something destructive to happen to our
precious earth
i hope not kevin i love that earth i
live there and well
hopefully there's an mcumt i would like
to think that there's an fdumt
doing this oh exactly so cute oh
what would that empty would he be doing
this or would you be like
well give me pictures of spiderman i'm
like honestly
i hope i'm working for like i don't know
baskin robbins
[Laughter]
oh yeah you would absolutely be killed
if you worked at the best
the same basket robin's from ant-man one
that ant-man
that's where i would be working okay are
we about to see the humans of the mcu
running for the last evacuation ships
off of a dying planet are we ultimately
doomed i think so
okay let's start by taking a look at
some of the exiled and extinct
civilizations that we've already come
across
in the mcu starting with of course the
latest one momentous one they live on
the livable moon of a planet called
lamentus and according to the
timekeepers everyone on this moon is
supposed to die when the planet lamentus
fully breaks apart and comes crashing
into it and we don't know the reason
behind the destruction of lamentus this
planet had only originally appeared in
annihilation conquest prologue number
one before it appeared in loki
and in that comic lamentis is described
as an outworld on the edge of cree space
and if this
lamentus in the show is similar then
it's possible
that this is a timeline where zandar and
the nova corps
are not around to protect the lamentus
likely thanks to the actions of
thanos as we saw in avengers infinity
war or was alluded to in avengers
infinity war rather i would have loved
to see it
in avengers infinity war but i i won't
be greedy
it would have been really cool
oh i read after the movie i was reading
an interview that made me so mad and it
stuck with me forever of them being like
there's just too many stones they're
like there's too many stones and we
didn't want to do
exposition on every stone and i was like
i wanted to see every stone
i wanted to see seriously like at least
put it in the dvd extras all right just
like yeah oh yeah yeah
do it reshoot the entire thing i need
this
but yeah i i'm still salty about it
maybe i'm just salty today
anyway without the protection of someone
like the cree it could lead to a
situation
where the people on the mentis one are
about to be destroyed by the collapsing
planet and speaking of thanos he is the
cause of many of the displaced
and destroyed civilizations in the mcu
so let us check out some of this
man's purple handiwork because he has
purple hands he cannot do handiwork if
the
handiwork is not purple oh yeah remember
that kids i remember those hands
do you know do you the tails those hands
could tell
you're killing me killing the baby call
the horny
you're getting bombed by the horny dog
okay and of course we've got to start
off with zandar zandar is of course the
home of the
zandarians as well as a bunch of other
alien species
and zandar is also the capital of the
nova empire and home base of the nova
corps
and zandar was home to 12 billion people
and then
at least half of them were wiped out by
thanos in 2018
when he came to get the power stone and
we assume that he did his little
50 50 trick because thor just tells the
guardians that he
decimated zandar so we don't know the
exact um
thing that thanos did to zandar at this
point we're just going to assume that he
just killed half of the people so in
order for thanos to destroy xandar
thanos definitely had to have wiped out
the novacore as they would have
fought to the very last soldier to stand
in his way and this would have
had a huge impact on the galaxy as the
nova corps are basically the highway
patrol of the stars
and without them around to keep the peas
things would get out of hand super fast
like really fast
could you imagine the world without the
highway patrol it would you know how
good our life would be
we would be free going as fast as we
wanted tickets we wouldn't be getting
you guys hear me out seriously
um we could have our own autobahn
going back to the zandarians um if the
nova corps are not existent
then there has to be like at least a few
left because it's also just like
it's uh as novacorps are people but it's
also like uh
like a value it's also like people just
just like the nova corps that are like
i'm gonna become the nova corps
so i feel like there's still some nova
corps out there in the universe
but this planet definitely doesn't have
that many yeah there definitely has to
be
some type of nova survivor or survival
of
the nova um the hive mind or i forget
what it's called
yeah the world mind and also if the
world mind and so in nova the world mind
and which it doesn't have to tie too
much of the comics but in the comics
where the nova straight up
took over a bunch of people and was like
mind controlling them so they wouldn't
leave
she could just or it could do that again
and just bring
more people into the nova corps i mean
to be fair the normal corpse lose
not lose a lot but they like lose most
of their people a lot
so it's like all for nothing but they
could easily bring more people in oh
yeah
it's a all you need is the world mind to
brainwash people
yeah just like highway patrol
just like the highway for sure and like
with the with the uh with the
introduction of the eternals coming up
in the movie and the the concept of the
unimined and all this stuff and
a little bit of what we've seen with the
the supreme intelligence in captain
marvel
who is like basically the amalgamation
of all the
the past three um people that have lived
into one
huge mega brain i think that it's it's
not um
impossible for us to see the world not
the world mind very soon
okay so next up is the zahobari gamora's
people the zohobery are
a brace of green-skinned humanoids from
the planet zen
ho ho huberi he's intact
wow from the planet zen huberi and these
people are gamora's people and we know
from infinity war what happened to the
zohovery the poverty and starvation was
a problem on their home world so thanos
showed up
to do a little bit of you know resource
reallocation you know what i'm saying
where that basically meant killing half
of everybody on that planet which wasn't
very nice but
he did get a daughter out of that whole
thing so everything's coming up thanos
hey hey just because you still
steal a child doesn't mean it's not your
child doesn't mean that's not your kid
that's you're you're the daddy now
that's just the rules of dad's work
you know what mad i'd be to be another
kid to see her survive
and then choose her why not me he's like
why do i have to die
i like to think that thanos had like a
pageant not a pageant but like a
competition
where like he had all these little kids
compete to live like
i'm just saying the hunger games
now while thanos may claim that his
actions brought about prosperity to the
remaining 50
of people that survived the nova corps
database indicated that the species is
now
functionally extinct and gamora is the
last of her kind and this could be true
for most of the planets that thanos
tried to correct
wiping out half of the population
doesn't always get rid of the
civilization's problems instead
it creates a whole new host of economic
and societal issues
as we saw in falcon winter soldier
pretty much and maybe thanos should have
worked on this map a little bit more
when he went around screwing with other
people's planets
so come on thanos i mean i know you're a
genius and all but uh
let's do the math next time okay he said
oopsies i'm not really thinking that far
he's like ah murder first think about it
second you know
god genocide aside and next up is the
kailos
the kylotians hail from kylos and are
the species where drax comes from
and they suffer the fate of thanos
desire to rebalance the universe and
we're massacred by ronan the accuser and
we don't know as much about the
continued existence of this species that
takes
everything super literally which is the
best part of that species but
if they suffer the same fate as the
zehobury after thanos balancing act then
their bloodlines
may have petered out as well or maybe
they're all just standing perfectly
still and we can't see them which is
also very likely
that'd be hilarious if like that'd be
hilarious if that's how the planet
worked if like the planet didn't move
but like you couldn't see it because it
just didn't move so your brain can't
perceive it
that'd be good i thought you were going
to say that if everybody on the planet
was drax
and i was like oh god
[Laughter]
i mean that's basically what it sounds
like because they all take everything
literally so they're all basically just
draxes
that is hilarious so next up are the
dwarves of nadivalier and thanos wiped
out these dwarves except for
entry and these were the dwarves that
ran the star forge that they used to
make
mjolnir the infinity gauntlet and
eventually stormbreaker which you know
is thanos's little axe x-ax
axe i mean really an oversight by thanos
to leave entry around but yet
another species wiped out by thanos
nonetheless so
it wasn't as like a it wasn't he didn't
do it as an act of like
see what happens when you work with me
it was more so he killed him to be like
i can't kill you because i need someone
to still make my stuff yeah he's like
you're gonna kill all your people he's
like thanks for the gauntlet still
killed them and was like also can you
make me like
a gold spoon it's like you make some
pretty good
so uh you know do you think you could
make me a shake weight like you killed
my people he's like i'ma let you live
because your etsy is pretty awesome
i saw the etsy account and them socks
are fired dude
them gold solid gold socks and next we
have
the titans if we gotta remember the
titans now and thanos would not even
have been on this mission if he didn't
witness
the extension of his people of titan and
even on titan
overpopulation and a lack of resources
led to the extinction of a species
and thanos is the only survivor that we
know about from titan i mean we could
have you know star fox
around there we could have a lars still
around here just doing whatever they're
doing
because they are eternal so they're very
long-lived people yeah and but this does
goes to show how the destruction of just
one species
can have immense ripple effects on the
cosmos in general and if everything had
just been fine and dandy on titan
so much needless death could have been
avoided completely or if they would have
just
killed thanos yeah killing thanos as a
baby would have been pretty great
crazy thing about thanos and titan is
the fact that
he saw this problem and his first
instinct was like wow we'd have more
food and resources if we just
killed half of us so he goes to the
leader tells the leaders that and the
leaders are like you're
insane half of us to feed them
he's like don't worry about it it's
gonna be completely random and they're
like bro you're insane
it's literally insane it's such an
insane idea
and he he like the the the fact that he
couldn't think of he couldn't brainstorm
any other right
any other way like we could eat less
meat we could just you know
recycle it's like no we got to kill half
we've tried nothing and we're all out of
ideas
he said if we kill half of us and then
they're just like
oh who are you choosing to kill he's
like well first
doug my neighbor he's always snooping
around oh the mailman that keeps putting
my mail on my neighbor's inbox
oh like it's just like how do you right
it's like he's like oh it can't be me
because i
i we need someone smart enough to decide
to kill people
like okay what about the idea and next
up are of course
the scrolls right i don't know if you
remember in captain marvel them being
exiled or on the run was a very big
point of that movie okay so in the mcu
the skrulls home planet of skrollos has
been destroyed by the cree
following a genocidal war and this has
the scroll scattered
across the galaxy hiding out wherever
they can and we're really going to see
this play out in this upcoming secret
invasion
series with nick fury and talos and all
that fun stuff which which is probably
gonna be a super wild ride and i can't
wait for it but
could they be coming to take earth from
us or perhaps steal another planet from
an unsuspecting species
it sucks because in the comics the
scrolls and the cree are both not
inherently like they're not good or bad
because it's like they both
want to do terrible things that they
have threats posed on earth all the time
but in the mcu i'm which correct me if
i'm wrong
i'm thinking that they're making the
scrolls the good people so you're going
to make them free the bad people they
so the scrolls that we follow in the in
captain marvel they are good scrolls but
like
yes scrolls are a huge race of people
and like they're all
probably like there's probably good
scrolls and bad scrolls so like the
girls girls were probably like hey
planet earth was pretty crazy and then
the other schools were like wait a
minute planet earth
you mean that's free real estate it's
free real estate
let's say that and so it's like oh wait
we can't just do that
we can't just do that why am i dude i
have this weird feeling that they're
setting up taylor's daughter
to be a bad squirrel a bad squirrel yeah
oh and taylor says like has to go off
against his daughter
to like you know save the planet because
i wouldn't eat that
i would eat that i hope so and of course
we have
the asgardians and as we all saw
ragnarok finally came to asgard when
serder
fulfilled his destiny and destroyed the
asgardian's home world but
as odin told us asgard is not a place
asgard is where our people stand
which is a very smart way to never make
sure your home base never truly gets
destroyed and those asgardians that
survived ragnarok have found a new place
on midgard but they could be on the run
again soon if earth faces annihilation
and i think of course it's worth
bringing up groot because his story is
one of
exile while the flora colosse weren't
wiped out our very own group was
exiled from the planet x after he fought
some of his vegetative brethren when he
saw them being too mean
to other helper mammals and the flora
colossi don't appear to leave their
planet often making group
a very rare sight in the galaxy if you
look back to you guarding to the galaxy
vol 1
when the collector who's seen like a ton
of different species sees groot he's
like
what is this who are you i've never seen
you before so
the flora colossi are very very rare so
again groot story is also one of exile
and searching
for a new home which leads us to the
dark elves from
thor 2. um even those evil and of the
universe loving
dark elves are displaced people
originally hailing from spartalheim one
of the nine realms they had to go on the
run after pissing off king boer
thor's grandpa who fought a mighty war
king boar fought
the mighty war i don't know why i love
that line so much but i'll always bring
it up but after spending some time
chilling in suspended animation
the dark elves came back to end the
universe once again but this time floor
pretty much wiped them all out i mean we
saved pretty much because
we did see a dark elf in the collector's
collection
before it went kablooey so we don't
really know exactly how many else dark
elf survived that altercation but
they're they're pretty much
all wiped out because you don't really
see them again but maybe there's still a
single dark elf out there just looking
for a new home
who knows i think that'd make a really
fun series just like
a dark elf hitchhiking thumb up just
like i just need a new home
i mean i don't know if i would take a
dark elf because they're super creepy
like they're very creepy and then of
course we have gore the god butcher in
floor of love and thunder we're going to
be introduced to gore
the god butcher and wouldn't you know it
his backstory in the comics
also involves a race of people
struggling to survive
and facing annihilation in the comics
gore comes from a planet with no name
where society consistently teeters
on the brink of starvation and they're
told to trust the gods and that the gods
would provide
and answer their prayers but gore just
sits and waits
while no god shows up and pretty much
his whole family dies
so this sets him up on a path of revenge
to wipe out all of these gods
who never bothered to help his people
it's actually a very sad story
and i sort of get the frustration gore
but murder is never the answer unless
you know
i don't you've never been a villain you
don't
understand them like you don't
understand the struggle
i don't know also my i don't know why
i don't know how i cannot figure out for
the life of me
why these are my favorite stories but
stories where people are like in the
comics
series where they're like waiting for
gods to come help them and the gods
never
show it's depressed it's depressing but
it's like i think it's because
we see so much of the gods and by the
guys we see like so much of thor and his
family and everybody and asgard
that when we go to the normal comic
books of
the villains that are just like waiting
for their answers to be heard by these
people
and they're not getting it answered and
then they die i'm always like
yeah that make me mad no i i i can bring
up a really good point because like that
that is our interesting perspective
where like you know the gods and the
heroes that can't be everywhere
but when they show up do you know how
hard it must be
and i mean that's the reason for the
writing but do you know how hard it must
be
to like be like thor is my god and you
never see him until like
new york is under fire by loki and
you're just like i've been
praying to you my daughter is dead
she's dead she's starved to death
because of you
like i get it it's not the same but it's
it kind of like that's why i like black
adam so much
like his story of like vengeance against
like
just kind of basically capitalism it's
like well
now it is back in the day it was like i
was a slave and
i wanted to kill all the masters now
it's like oh
uh i see all these people in this like
company
being worked to death i'm gonna go kill
their boss but like
it's like i'm like yeah i'm like go
ahead go ahead go go
with your bad self go do what you gotta
do
anger is justified no i really like that
because uh
if you think about you know asgard as a
people and as a place in their history
they're basically like the one percent
they're the rich people and like
yeah they all you know and so like
they're up on their you know their high
horse
and like looking down at everybody well
meanwhile everyone else is suffering and
like it isn't this
amazing paradise everywhere else and
like the asgardians aren't doing
anything so yeah like you said
they're not i do like that perspective a
lot because like that does give gore
some some
some what do you call it yeah i can't
wait i can't wait for gore the god
butcher it's gonna it's
christian bale that dude's gonna knock
it out of the park he's going mikey
that dude he's a method actor so he
probably is just out there and outer
space
living it he's just wouldn't be
surprised if we hear that natalie
portman got killed on set because he
picked her up and threw her somewhere
because he is he's that crazy he's like
oops accidentally he's not joking
he's not jared leto you know joker crazy
but he is
a method acting i'm gonna be detrimental
to my own
act i feel like it's hard to reach that
jared leto level of uh
extra it's not hard you just don't have
to do it you just don't have to do it
that's all it is
just don't do it act when you have that
first thought where you're like
hmm should i send my my like
and my coworkers weird stuff just don't
do it yeah you know usually that's why
we have hr departments
hey paul
[Music]
okay so as you can see there are plenty
of examples of displaced and destroyed
populations
throughout the mcu but is this all just
a primer for our own fate
could earth be the one in the crosshairs
soon i don't know but let's
do a rundown of some possible
destructive forces that could be facing
the planet
starting with you know the most obvious
and the most on our minds
the celestials because the celestials be
destroying planets i don't know if you
notice but
they love to do that it's basically a
sport to them these armored a-holes are
for sure going to make
their presence known in the upcoming
eternals film and we already know that
they have a penchant for blowing up
planets that they see as failures in the
genetic science fair
but could they be coming for earth next
i mean we can only hope that the
eternals have a plan
to save us or at the very least uh a
place for us to escape to you because
that'd be
nice to not be destroyed by uh
celestials just uh doing science
it'd be cool to see them not cool today
one of my biggest fee
this is this is like legit 100 true i
probably shouldn't put this on the
internet
but like one of my biggest irrational
fears
is seeing a big face in the sky like a
big
face like you know like show me what you
got
scenario that exactly show me that exact
scenario
would i would freak the out because
my brain could not process oh god
so like when they make earth perform on
the
universal version of american idol
someone else i passed out i passed out
and or died because that's that's a
weird i don't know what i would do
i would just be like well time to steal
big face in the sky time to steal i
guess well i wouldn't
i would be going to like target
i'd be going like target i wouldn't be
going to like
my neighbor's house i'm not gonna break
into people's house i'm just gonna break
into target capitalism
i'm here to take it down i dig it trying
okay so the celestials obviously are you
know probably the
main threat to earth at this moment in
time
galactus is still a thing and with a
fantastic four coming up we could see
galactus coming up very soon but of
course galactus is the devourer of
worlds so it only makes sense that he
would eventually crave
the tastiest world that there is earth
because i hear it
it tastes like um i don't know pollution
gas
gases galactus is a classic big bad in
marvel comics and like i said before
with the fantastic four coming to the
mcu soon there's a chance that we could
see galactus soon as well and so that's
galactus but another
really uh likely scenario for earth
destruction could be
the annihilation wave now remember back
to the beginning of the episode when we
were talking about lamentist one
and how lamentis has only appeared in
comics only once before well
fun fact that comic that the planet
first appeared in had to do with the
annihilation wave the annihilation wave
is of course the interdimensional army
of annihilus a conqueror from the
negative zone and his only fear is death
so he spends his time
taking this huge planet-destroying
annihilation wave across dimensions
wiping out anyone who stands in his way
and with lamentas coming to the mcu it
could be a nod to a future threat coming
to earth but now
speaking of threats we do have the
multiversal crisis that we assume is
coming up in
multiverse of madness or maybe even at
the end of loki and we've heard a lot
about the multiversal war
from the tva and loki and it could be a
real threat to the earth in this
dimension
and it's possible that the citizens from
an earth facing destruction in an
alternate dimension could come racing to
our earth for refuge or even vice versa
our dimension could need a new planet to
go to so we could be
hopping to another planet for uh for
help which would be uh kind of crazy
aren't we doing that right now we are
within i almost said elon tusk with elon
musk
i mean with with him setting that up out
of space
finding new new life don't even get me
started on that car
keep going and like i said before with
the next doctor strange film diving into
the multiverse of madness
we could be looking at something similar
to the recent secret wars comic event in
2015 which is one of my favorite comic
events
ever and pro i think the first comic
event i've ever read yeah in that event
battle world was set up comprised of
fragments of alternate marvel universes
and timelines
and the end results of secret wars
altered the main marvel universe
timeline and shuffled around
some key players from the multiverse and
that's how we have miles morales in the
main
marvel 616 universe because before he
was in um the ultimate universe
earth 1610 so you know the
if we have a secret war scenario happen
here we could see
another multiverse shuffle on a
cinematic scale we could get elements
from
the fox x-men we could get maybe even a
permanent uh you know what do you call
it tobey maguire
spider-man in the mcu who knows anything
can happen
but that is it for my answer for the
question
i mean hopefully uh the people of mcu
earth are not going to face exile soon
but it would be great
to see that especially if they do the
builder war like oh my god the builders
but before we continue on with this
video uh if you like what we do here on
new rockstars you can help us do more of
it by going to newrockstarsmerch.com
we've got t-shirts like this one i
finally got
my my swag i got this variant shirt from
newrockstarsmerch.com and it is
wonderful i feel
cooler than most people but yes we have
t-shirts
stickers buttons hats hoodies and all
kinds of cool stuff so head on over to
new rockstarsmerch.com to grab some cool
gear and help this channel out because
it really does
help the show so credit karma wants to
help you with a credit karma money spend
account get rewarded for good money
habits
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases
and when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win
daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items
up to five thousand dollars and just pay
with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added to your
spend account and credit karma money
has already given away over 3 million
dollars in instant karma open your fdi
insured account for free and when you
make a purchase between july 1st and
july 23rd
you'll be automatically entered to win 1
million dollars and right now
visit creditkarma.com win money to open
your free account and start winning
instant karma
go to creditkarma.com win money to sign
up for free and start winning
instant karma that's creditkarma.com win
money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms apply
c rules and banking services are
provided by mvb bank incorporated
member fdic maximum balance and transfer
limits apply and now it is time for our
bite size questions of the program and
our first bite size question of the day
is what are some of the strangest things
the venom symbiote has bonded with jess
and this is from that purple 57 on
twitter
which is great because did you write
this down i'd be drinking
some purple sometimes look at what you
guys did
that purple this is my purple water this
is water
but i like to drink it to keep me uh
hydrated
yeah yeah yeah sorry
that's completely real so there have
been truly insane and bizarre venom
symbiote combinations in marvel comics
and here are just a few of our favorites
specifically
mine and brandon's okay ready in an
alternate timeline there was a symbiote
merged with ben grimm to make a rock
solid venom
do you have the can you see the images
or do you remember if you remember them
just yell it at me hold on let me
because the ben grimm symbiote is
my type hold on let me see oh my god yes
that is 100
your type my type it is a big man
that is a brute of a man oh my god that
is like 100 thanos vibes right there
that is it destroys you like not like
sexually but like it
in a fight i would not go against that
hey why not both
is what i'm saying i'm just kidding
why not okay and then they also merged
with both rocket and groot
got a taste of the venom when the
guardians had to watch over the symbiote
for a bit
and the they're so it's real it's just
so funny because the
rocket is kind of cute and groot is also
kind of cute because groot is just like
i
don't know they look quite i mean groot
looks pretty terrifying rocket
uh rocket's a little bit less terrifying
but venom groups
terrifying again i love villains
everyone knows this so this entire list
is just my cup of tea i'm like these are
perfect
uh we got she venom when the symbiote
took over ann wayne
eddie brock's ex-wife we actually got a
small live-action taste of this in the
venom movie
also she venom itself is so cool
there was the time that venom bonded
with the t-rex from the savage land and
we got this badass
t-rex how are you talking about devil's
dinosaur is that what happened yeah and
oh my god you do not want this monster
coming at you in any way oh my god no
it's a monstrosity it's not devil
dinosaur i don't think but it's still a
monstrosity of uh
that's terrifying that is terrifying wow
love it
love it you thought of t-rex you thought
t-rex by itself was terrifying
just wait until the venom seriously the
symbiote
gets attached to this monster jurassic
world would be a different franchise i'm
telling you right that right now
honestly it's probably the same because
the t-rex in jurassic park
that was this whole thing it was like
it's killing for sport or it's killing
for fun
which is just like that's true this is
true that's a good point
good point jurassic park just realized
just took venom
okay so we have the t-rex venom we have
spider-ham has faced a villain named
pork rind
who looks like the symbiote-covered pig
and seems to have all the same abilities
of course that's the one that you
chuckle at
uh poor grind is super cool it's a great
gamer tag take it if you haven't already
and the image
is so fun
and then finally according to the
deadpool's secret secret wars
the symbiote bonded with deadpool before
it bonded with peter parker
that would make deadpool the symbiote's
first contact with a
wow i had no idea yeah like that's so
like
when it comes to like the more comedic
comics like your deadpool's or your
squirrel girls
it's like they keep making funny little
retcons like this where it's just like
oh like oh
he was the first one because it's funny
that way
but like is this this is like really
canon i guess it is canon because it's
marvel
it's now it is they're so preoccupied
with whether or not they could they
didn't stop to think they should
now it is i a side note i started um i
read
squirrel girl when i was younger thought
it was fun i was
like i didn't really attach it to the
mcu because it didn't feel like that
when i was reading it when i was a child
now i'm rereading it and i'm like god
she's so
great she's so funny i love her
reread squirrel girl everybody the whole
comic is ridiculous
in the best way like please rescue them
so those are a few of our favorite
symbio characters that have
there's also obviously more but these
are our favorite ones these ones are
very cartoony very fun also
great to see and uh the mcu if they do
come into the environment
for sure but for our second question we
have
from grin and barrack on twitter which
is our off greens producer
uh brandon thank you brandon never
change them
harley quinn have powers great freaking
question i love me somebody's great
love me sometimes i mean we got suicide
squad coming up so it's all about harley
these days
baby baby it's always been hardly for me
so
the short answer is that harley quinn
doesn't have real superpowers and we're
gonna get into it
but she's so she's she's no normal
average joe
obviously or a transformation she was
gifted uh she
had a genius level iq and she was the
most badass gymnast
she was literally could have been the
olympics like she's
amazing but those aren't super powers
it's just talented they are in terms of
these people are super heroes for us
today but in
the comic book world that's not a
superpower she's
just amazing so the character was
originally conceived from a batman anime
series from the 90s
but she quickly became a fan favorite
and was absorbed into the comics
her original origin had her simply
driven insane by the joker
but that has been since revised her
story now involves her being dumped into
the same
chemicals that the joker was
transforming her skin and high nearing
her sanity but there's so many different
things that it could be
that there is no definitive line except
for in like
one comic book issue a long time ago
where he's like 98 percent sodium
20 this and it's like you can make it
from home kids
you want to make crap it's like no it
does
we're going to leave it here with saying
that it's we don't know what's the
chemical that's in there
but it has been insinuated that they
should have killed a normal person
so the fact that the both the joker and
harley quinn survived the dunks must
mean that they are some sort of
very special person and also um in the
comics poison ivy injected harley with a
special toxin antidote that made her
immune to various forms of chemicals
as well as gave her enhanced strength
and durability in addition she has
mastery of weapons and fighting ability
in the dceu
there has been no indication of her
receiving the injection from poison ivy
though she does seem to possess some
enhanced durability as seen in suicide
squad and birds of prey
she also has a pretty substantial
ability to hold her alcohol
and cocaine at times if you saw birds
prey
amanda waller does say that harley is
crazier than the joker so
maybe that's her greatest power and
obliviousness to danger that makes her
invulnerable to fear and intimidation
which
is i would say power um also
also side note i guess um thinking about
it there was like one other person that
had the acid
that harley quinn and joker did but not
to the extension of what joker and
harley did
joker and harley dunk themselves in the
acid um joker also has been known to do
it more than once
so it's like yeah he's just crazy but
like i think it was the creeper
that turned into the creeper because the
scientist injected him with the same vat
of acid
that harley and joker had
but it wasn't he wasn't dunked in it he
just had it injected to him so maybe a
small dose of it
can just but like it can make you crazy
but um those are like the three that i
know of
that it definitely has happened to so
yeah maybe you do have to be a form of
special human in order to dunk yourself
like i wonder what makes these two crazy
people so special
that they don't immediately die i don't
think it's that they're special
it's like the same with radiation where
it's like in
this is a horrible example but one of my
favorite episodes of
a family guy was they accidentally fell
into this radiation
and then they all got super powers and
then adam west was like i'm
gonna do the same thing and then he got
really sick
they were like they were like why would
you do that he was like well they got
powers he was like yeah
you're sick now so i don't know i think
it's just like different people
different bodies like but maybe they
have strong immune systems so it didn't
kill us
i think it's all gymnastics that harley
does i think she's
primed her body oh yeah but joker
doesn't do just running around the city
just being crazy i think that burns
do you want to take it to the next
session the next the next
box which is the box subscribe
no one cared who i was to like
who loves the box of scraps empty and
jess love this box of scraps
is that your box of scraps
i do i do i do i do
look at what you did look at what you
guys did to mt
he's going insane he's been dunked in
the air i'm so sorry all right
oh who's kell kelly are you kel
oh no no no no between the two of us i
think we're both
so today's box of scraps question is do
you still buy and read monthly comics
and if so
which comics do you read and why and
this comes from mj in santa fe on
discord so thank you mj in santa fe
beautiful name um i'm right now i'm
reading everything on marvel unlimited
anytime there's a new series or movie
coming out for marvel i like to re-read
as much as i can of the comic
um to refresh so like for loki i was
reading as much
thor comics as i could um i read like
the
2010 loki issues um even the little ones
on the side
uh it's good it's like 10 a month
um and it has almost everything on there
and it has like all of the older like
70s
and like 60s original issues like most
of them so it's really fun to look back
at it
digitally nice all right i do i love
marvel
unlimited if you guys don't have marvel
unlimited and you
want to get into reading marvel comics
it's literally the best way it's
literally the entire
library essentially in an easy to
use way and like go for it this is not
an ad i just really like
marvel unlimited it is a great and it's
like you don't even
if you're so new to comics and you're
just like i just want to specifically
read about
this person you can just type in the
name and yeah they will actually
package everything so very smartly in
the marvel limited app so like
it's it's the best place to go to if you
if you want to if you're first getting
into comics
um again not an ad we just generally
love marvel unlimited
give me free marvel unlimited marvel you
heard this kevin feige
and dc infinite dc infinite as well dc
infinite same price
same stuff you can read all the old
freaking
wonder womans and all the old uh
everything it's really good both of them
yes
for me i i'm not reading any monthly
comics right now i
i do like to keep up with the comics as
much as i can
but like this time has been kind of
rough for me but i i have been rereading
one of my favorite comic series of all
time
which is uh strangers in paradise um if
you don't know strange in paradise this
is like super old
comic um i'm merely mentioning this
because it's pride month
and it's it's about these two girls and
they're
i don't know they're weird adventures
that they go on as they slowly you know
start to realize that they like each
other it's a really it's a really really
good i'm not
doing the synopsis justice but um i i
highly recommend it's about
two girls strangers in paradise because
it's a it's a nice little fun
it's not superheroes or anything it's
just a story
um oh i i have a same plug girl from the
sea by molly
um by molly oster tag it's
a pride and it's a young lesbian tale
about a mermaid and a girl and they fall
in love and it's really good
and also um read lumberjanes i just
read lumberjanes oh yes
lumberjanes is great lumberjanes is so
freaking good so funny lumberjanes is a
good one lumberjanes and i think i said
it on this again
lumberjanes and rat queens are two
really good just like female driven
like just badasses just badass planet
can't forget about planet someone
someone from someone watching this our
podcast went and
like bought planet for their wife
and then i tagged
um i oh my gosh how did i just forget
her name kelly sudaconic
and she immediately was like thanks for
spreading awareness
that's so cool that's so cool i love her
i love her oh everybody reads sweet
tooth now that it's on netflix jeff
lemire
um sweet tooth yeah such a good oh sweet
tooth is really good
and i haven't watched the series yet on
netflix but i love
sweet tooth so much but that is it for
this episode of big question i want to
give a huge thank you to jess for
joining me this episode you can follow
her at luluclemons
she tweets amazing stuff so please
please follow her you can follow me
mastertainment i tweet slightly way less
amazing stuff than jess
so please follow us both on the twitter
machines but most importantly follow us
on new rockstars wherever we are
especially on youtube
and hit that notification bell so you
get notifications whenever we upload
a video alright take it easy everybody
we love you bye
[Music]
you